joe biden ignored d-day
he neglected it instead
he posted a video of himself meeting
with the survivors
of the tulsa race riot he says
he tweets quote i met with survivors of
the tulsa massacre this week
to help fill the silence because in
silence wounds deepen
and as painful as it is only in
remembrance do wounds heal what's he
talking about
what is he talking about i think the
wounds from the tulsa race riot had
healed
a hundred years ago the wounds that no
one was talking about at all
he's picking that scab he wants people
to focus on them
he doesn't want people to talk about
d-day that was glorious and makes
america look good
he wants to talk about this long
forgotten race riot because that makes
america look bad
now he won't talk about every race riot
he won't for instance talk about the
race riot
that happened during the summer of last
year the race riot
race i'm sorry race riots in which blm
burns down multiple cities around the
country he's not talking about that
but the but mr president the wounds are
going to fester
they're going to deepen if we don't no
we're not allowed to talk about that
we're not allowed to talk about how blm
burned down
minneapolis and washington dc and new
york and cities
all over the country no because that
contradicts the narrative
that doesn't advance the premise that
america is a white supremacist terrible
country
actually instead of talking about those
race riots joe biden instead
meets with the family of george floyd
violates the coronavirus lockdowns
to show up to the funeral of george
floyd where many many thousands of
people were going at the height of the
apparent pandemic he doesn't want to
talk about that he doesn't want to heal
any wounds he wants to pick wounds
because this is about framing
the way to prove this by the way is to
show it's
it's not even just about race it's
simply about
framing the country as it is as evil as
pretext for the radicals to give
revolution you saw the same thing happen
up in canada
so justin trudeau also while he was
supposed to be commemorating the 77th
anniversary of d-day
did not mention d-day it was canadian
armed services day
coinciding with d-day he doesn't mention
d-day instead he addresses quote
sexual misconduct and gender-based
violence in the military
what this is this is canadian armed
services day this is the day we're
supposed to celebrate
the armed forces of canada and their
heroic efforts no we're just going to
talk about how terrible they are
this is why now in america
we don't talk about our glories we don't
talk about
the fourth of july we don't we barely
talk about
our our veterans when we do we just talk
about them as a bunch of hapless
schmucks oh they were shipped overseas
to a pointless war they didn't it's not
as though they died for our freedom for
anything
useful or purposeful no no and we
shouldn't focus on that anyway
there's memorial day and there's pride
month you know which
oh god a little bit we'll talk about
really we've got to focus on
grievance we've got to talk about
radical left
identity groups there was actually a
proposal another
day that is not has not been very
important in american history but
all of a sudden the left is trying to
make it important is juneteenth
this is one of many days that marked the
end of the civil war
but the left is trying to make this into
a really big deal and there was a
proposal by a republican senator
to make juneteenth a federal holiday but
how are they going to do it
they can't just keep making federal
holidays you know the people got to go
work
so the proposal was to make juneteenth a
federal holiday to replace columbus day
so we're going to make a day that is now
largely focused on racial grievance and
pushing forth a racial narrative
we're going to have that replace the
glorious day of the founding
and discovery of the new world all
about framing
[Music]
you